Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesis Gechirpest durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Okay?
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Florian Krohn.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, natürlich. Florian Krohn.
Okay. Wie soll ich Sie sprechen? Also Herr oder Frau Krohn?
Herr. Vielleicht.
Herr Krohn, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, 540 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
12.05.1980
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,87 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
750.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen. Herr Krohn, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, ich war im Wald gestern Nachmittag mit meinem Hund spazieren, als ich ihm plötzlich hinterher laufen musste.
Ich habe einen losen Stein übersehen. Deswegen bin ich gestorben und mit dem linken Fuß nach innen umgeknickt.
Seitdem habe ich starke Schmerzen im linken Sprunggelenk.
Herr Krohn, können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind Sie eher drückend oder dumpf oder stechend?
Ja, stechend.
Okay. Und sind diese Schmerzen mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden oder besser geworden?
Daher schlimmer geworden.
Okay. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Ja, 8.
Herr Krohn, das ist eine starke Schmerzen. Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ja, unser Gespräch, wie lange dauert?
Ca. 15 Minuten.
Ja, ja. Ich warte auf.
Okay. Ich werde mich beeilen. Danke Ihnen. Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie eine Schmerzmittel benötigen.
Okay.
Okay. Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo aus?
Nein.
Herr Krohn, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt? Haben Sie bemerkt? Ich meine Hochlagerung, Tieflagerung?
Ja, die Hochlagerung ja, die Schmerzen lindert. Aber wenn ich laufe, die Schmerzen stärken.
Okay. Haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Nein.
Okay. Waren Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Okay. Gibt es eine Bewegungseinschränkung beim Fuß? Ich meine bewegen Sie den Fuß einfach oder?
Ja, ja, ja.
Gibt es Probleme beim Bewegung?
Ja, ja, ja, natürlich.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Traubhaltsgefühl oder Kribbeln bei diesem Arzt?
Unter Traubhaltsgefühl und Kribbel auch. Blau hat Verfarbung am linken Fuß und Schwellung.
Okay. Herr Krohn, haben Sie eine offene Wunde bemerkt?
Wie bitte?
Abschürfungen oder offene Wunde, haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, nein.
Okay. Herr Krohn, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie mit dem linken Fuß umgeknickt haben.
Darf ich fragen, sind Sie auf dem Boden hintergefallen oder nur umgeknickt?
Nein, nur innen umgeknickt.
Okay, alles klar. Und haben Sie sich Ihren Kopf nicht verletzt?
Nein, nein.
Okay. Also, ich möchte fragen, ob Sie eine komische Situation vor der Stolperung bemerkt?
Ich meine, schwarz vor den Augen oder Schwindel?
Nein, nein.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie errechnen?
Nein, auch nicht.
Und fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Nein.
Oder haben Sie einen Schmuckdachweis?
Okay. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stürgang?
Was soll ich sagen? Ja, das war normal, aber seit fünf Jahren habe ich ein nervöser Daumen-Syndrom.
Und manchmal habe ich Durchfall, Bleihungung, manchmal Bauchschmerzen.
Aber aktuell habe ich keinen Durchfall.
Okay. Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Nehmen Sie gegen diese Beschwerden?
Ja, Chima.
Können Sie das bitte wiederholen?
Chima. K-I-J-I-M-A.
Chima. Okay.
Chima.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Bei Bedarf. Wegen Diary oder Beleidigungen.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, mein Appetit ist gut.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklig ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Das freut mich. Okay.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Seit gestern Abend habe ich Schlafstörungen wegen Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, beide.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, vollständig.
Und Wundstar-Krampf geimpft?
Ja, ja.
Alles, ich meine, ja?
Ja.
Wann war Ihre letzte Tetanus-Impfung? Erinnern Sie sich?
Ja, ja. Aber ich erinnere mich nicht, wann es genau war.
Okay. Alles klar.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin, Herr Krone?
Ja, mein Hausarzt, Frau Schühler.
Frau Schühler. Okay. Ich werde Ihren Hausärztin kontaktieren. Okay?
Okay.
Reiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen voran, denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, seit drei Jahren habe ich Arthritis vor Rika.
Und vor drei Wochen habe ich akute Arthritis.
Aber jetzt habe ich keine Schmerzen, keine Schwellung.
Vor fünf Jahren, nach einem Motorradunfall,
Bandscheibenvorfall im Lendenbereich,
wurde bei mir konservativ behandelt.
Physiotherapie, Krankengymnastikübungen, Schmerzmittel und so weiter.
Seit fünf Jahren habe ich ein nervoses Darm-Syndrom.
Manchmal habe ich Durchfall, Blähung und Bauchschmerzen.
Ich nehme Kishimea ein.
Seit 15 Jahren habe ich Schreiknöcheln mit Dysphonie.
Und Behandlung.
Ich nehme alle drei, vier Stunden nur ein Luchstablet ein.
Alle drei, vier Stunden, haben Sie gesagt.
Herr Krone, Sie leiden an Arthritis Rika.
Darf ich fragen, in welchem Körperregion hatten Sie Probleme?
Vor drei Wochen?
Ja, Fuß.
Und welche Seite?
Rechte Seite.
Besonders große See?
Ja, große See.
Ok.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, vor fünf Jahren.
Wegen einer Bucitis-Schleimentzündung im rechten Kniegelenk.
Operation wurde durchgeführt.
Sonst noch etwas?
Nur eine Operation.
Ok.
War diese Operation komplikationslos verlaufen?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten noch andere Medikamente ein?
Ja, Allopyrinol, Neuangin, Luchstabletten, Ibuprofen und Imodium.
Ok. Kennen Sie die Dosierung von Allopyrinol? Und wie oft nehmen Sie an?
Ja, drei, 100 mg einmal morgen.
Ok. Und wogegen nehmen Sie Ibuprofen ein? Darf ich fragen? Auch gegen Arthritis Rika oder?
Ja, ja.
Ok. Welche Dosierung?
800 mg.
Ok. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein oder bei Bedarf?
Ja, bei Bedarf.
Ok. Und Imodium, Tablet nehmen Sie auch bei Bedarf oder?
Ja, ja.
Ok. Alles klar.
Sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Ja, ich habe Latexallergien und Frühblutallergien.
Ja, ich habe Latexallergien mit Rotung und Hautauschlag.
Frühblutallergien mit Juckreis und Nasenlaufen und Nissen, Augenlaufen.
Ok. Alles klar.
Auch schon.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unfertigkeiten gegen Nahrungsmittel?
Nein.
Ok. Herr Krone, rauchen Sie?
Seit 5 Jahren bin ich nicht Raucherin, aber früher 20 Zigaretten täglich seit 15 Jahren.
Ok. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, am Wochenende trinke ich Ibiza.
Ibiza. Also, Bier meinen Sie?
Ja.
Herr Krone, ich habe nicht richtig verstanden.
Bier. Ok.
Wie viel Bier trinken Sie?
Ein oder zwei Flaschen Bier.
Ok. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Herr Krone, also, nehmen Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ja, früher als Kind, als Junge mit sechs Jahren habe ich Haschisch und Amphetamin probiert.
Ein oder zwei Mal.
Ok. Das war's. Sie haben keinen Kontakt mehr, ich glaube?
Ja.
Ok. Alles klar.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck gerauscht.
Und vor zwei Jahren bei meinem Vater wurde Linsentransplantation wegen Linsentrübung durchgeführt.
Beide Seiten oder eine Seite wissen Sie?
Eine Seite.
Welche Seite?
Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Ok. Alles klar. Herr Krone und Ihre Mutter?
Ja, meine Mutter hatte Bluthochdruck vor zwei Monaten.
Und aktuell wurde sie eine Operation durchgeführt und nachdem Strahlentherapie wurde durchgeführt, behandelt.
Ok. Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Brüderin. Aber bei ihr wurde eine Magenverkleinerung durchgeführt wegen Übergewicht.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ja, ich bin geschieden seit drei Jahren.
Aber ich wohne mit meinen lebenslosen Partnern.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, drei Kinder. Aber bei einer Person, die Hypochosis schwer ist, und ein Hörgerät.
Ok. Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Rechtsanwalt. Ich bin Rechtsanwalt.
Ihr habt Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, aber ich bin zufrieden.
Alles klar. Das waren meine Fragen, Herr Krone. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was habe ich, Herr Doktor? Ist es gefährlich oder nicht?
Herr Krone.
Kann man operiert werden?
Es ist zu früh, etwas genau zu sagen. Aber leider könnte es sein, dass Sie operiert werden müssen.
Zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen. Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Ok. Nach dieser Untersuchung können wir über eine 100% sicher Diagnose und Therapiemöglichkeiten sprechen.
Aber es gibt auch konservative Therapiemethoden ohne chirurgisches Eingriff.
Ok. Muss ich in die Röhre gehen?
Ach so. Sie meinen Tomographie oder ...
Ja, LRT.
Genau. Also, wie gesagt, es ist zu früh, aber das kann sein, Herr Krone. Aber machen Sie bitte keine Sorge.
Also, haben Sie eine Platzangst oder?
Ja, ja.
Ach so, ok. Kein Problem. Also, wenn Sie eine Platzangst haben, können wir Ihnen eine Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Damit können Sie sich ruhig fühlen. Ok?
Ja, ok. Danke.
Gerne. Danke.